foreign
how do I forgive myself for allowing
someone to mistreat me sometimes in a
situation like the one you're in
sometimes it's easier
blame ourselves because we feel like we
could actually fix that
[Music]
what in the world is going on this is
John with the Dr John deloney's show I'm
so grateful that you joined
the show we talk about everything real
people going through real challenges
talk about your marriages who you're
dating
loss grief your mental and emotional
health your kids whatever you got going
on in your life I spent the last two
decades sitting with people when the
wheels have fallen off and helping them
figure out what to do next and I'm so
honored that you've joined us if you
want to be on this show right into the
show
johndaloney.com
ask a-s-k go to John deloney.com
d-e-l-o-n-y slash ask and join us and
today is a huge
huge day it's exciting day
it's maybe my most exciting of a day
since I've been here
but I'm gonna shut up first and we're
gonna go straight to it stop what you're
doing
unless you're driving don't stop don't
stop but tell everybody in the car to be
quiet
if you're vacuuming or mowing just take
a second and stop for a second
I want you to listen to this if you're
on YouTube I want you just to stop
multitasking
focus in for just a second
check this out this is from a recent
talk I gave and I'll leave it at that
check it out
I know about you I know about you
and I know you're exhausted
and your kids are finally in bed
Maybe
they're playing video games and
hopefully they're making good choices
with strangers online here's the deal
it's quiet
the lights are low in the house they let
you know and when it's finally time for
bed your body commits an act of mutiny
because being an adult is trying
desperately to stay awake during the day
and trying to fall asleep at night and
you go to bed and you put on some
headphones and you listen to your murder
podcast because why do they keep coming
back to the scene or some of you put uh
like two talk show hosts that are like
the end of the world is coming and
you're like and that's your world right
and then then or you watch uh
reruns of the office or Ted lasso
because imaginary people and imaginary
TV shows are the last decent human
beings on the planet right and after a
while your eyes start Crossing
from all these screens
and your body's like I guess we're up
and so you find yourself in your
bathroom just crushing up Tylenol PM and
just snorting it off the counter
and you're not asleep but you're
unconscious
right until about 3 A.M and
your body's like we got crap we gotta
think about right now and you wake up
and then you're like I what if what if
my business fails what if it fails and
then you're like maybe maybe my business
would fail I don't even like my business
and then over here you're like what if
what if China invades Taiwan I know I
know it's gonna just disrupt world trade
in a way that we haven't seen it's
probably going to kickoff world war
three but I I can't do another three
months of homeschooling like covet I
can't do it right and then like hey you
know that kid that mole that mole on on
Jeffrey's back it's for sure cancer I'm
I know it's cancer and so there's one
place that we go we're gonna google it
let's Google it at 3am and try to solve
this
and then while you're scrolling you
happen by your bank account balance and
your credit card balance and your
stomach drops into your feet and you
think
I'm gonna have Hypersonic diarrhea right
now
and you're like how do we owe what and
then you think I could go kill
my husband and they would never find his
body because I listened to murder
podcast right and then you finally go go
to sleep and you sleep for about an hour
and your eyes pop open because of your
alarm and you drag yourself to the day
because you're Crossing it you're gonna
snap into a slim jim that I'm talking
about and you go work out and you turn
the water on the shower so hot it's
burning off your day and you get in the
shower at 7 58 for your eight o'clock
meeting
and you have a 20-minute commute and
then you get out of the shower and it's
8 40 and you are pissed at time just
kept going while you were in the shower
and then you get out of the shower
and you walk by the mirror
there's a couple of people in this room
and I've met you you just look at
yourself and you're like that's what I'm
talking about
[Laughter]
most of you
and you just stop stop and you're like
I don't think I believe in God anymore
right
and then you start mainlining coffee to
take the edge off the Tylenol PM you
snort it all night and then your
family's running around and you're
barking conversations like hey don't
forget to pick this up you have to put
on deodorant every day every day and I
told you to do that what do you mean
that's due today and then you're like
your mom is going to stay for how long
and then you make eye contact
and you're like
and she looks at you across the room and
she's like God no we're not having sex
I'm gonna have gas tonight no
and then you go into the garage to get
into your car and one of your kids just
barfs everywhere and instead of going oh
my gosh baby are you okay are you okay
your first thought is
if I just keep walking she will clean
this up right
and then you go to work and you're
standing next to this woman
and she's like oh my gosh I heard your
Keto
keto is amazing but you can't eat bacon
because of the fat Parts have you done
ancestry 23andMe it's amazing you should
totally wear barefoot shoes because
sitting is the new smoking but my friend
Sparrow she rolls her own organic
cigarettes and because because smoking
is the new standing and let's do
somersaults right and you just think to
yourself
I don't I don't want to be alive right
now
and then at 10 30 freaking Dan rolls up
and I've gotta fire Dan because Dan's
always late but Darren always
brings donuts and the only thing
that takes that image burned into my
soul
of me shirtless in front of the mirror
is
carbs and sugar it just shoves that
image down into my soul right and then
I'm walking to the bathroom and I hear
this from behind me
oh no no
I'm a cat dad and I turn
and he goes
it's it's way more challenging than
being a the parent of a child and then I
think I'm gonna go in the parking lot
and just set myself on fire to see if I
still feel pain all right and after a
fast food lunch of indigestion and
insulin and diarrhea and for those of
you keeping track that's that's diarrhea
reference number two right you have to
go to this Consulting meeting with this
idiot 22 year old with a master's degree
in leadership and the only thing he's
ever LED is a little rubber ducky around
his bathtub right and then you're
staring at spreadsheets and terrible
homemade marketing materials and you
can't wait to the day and you go get in
your car and you put on another murder
podcast because how hard is it to murder
stop talking about it after you do it
and then you go home and you sit on the
couch and you and your wife or you and
your husband on the couch and instead of
talking about how much you're
suffocating under all this debt and how
your calendar is stuffed tighter than
your marketing interns jeans and the
phone rings and your mother-in-law says
hey here's the next 14 years of
Thanksgiving plans and you don't want to
do any of it but if you say something to
her right there on the couch to your
wife or your husband
they're gonna kill you
and they listen to murder podcasts too
and they will never find your body
so you repeat you you you retreat
ESPN Fantasyland
can we take a second
fantasy Sports
where grown men
use other real grown men as action
figures
in imaginary games
[Laughter]
look you were there's a husband and a
wife on a couch
is playing imaginary games with real
other men
I'll give you dragons and trolls and
stuff
no this guy lives in your same city and
he's my guy right
and she is sitting right here looking up
line tattoos that say hashtag blessed on
her iPad and cauliflower mashed potato
recipes and she's looking at 18 year old
birthday parties your kid's nine by the
way y'all could be absolutely doing it
right now
[Laughter]
that makes no evolutionary sense and
you're four inches apart from each other
and you're four thousand miles away
and then you snort a bunch of Tylenol PM
off the counter
this is our day this is our day this is
what we call normal this is my day this
is your day this is our life
this is insane and then we go to a
doctor we go to a doctor or a counselor
on the Internet or some therapist and we
say I'm anxious I'm so anxious I've got
anxiety I'm chronically stressed I'm
burned out and the doctor says well it
sucks to be you because anxiety is a
disease it's a genetic disorder and it's
in your brain it can only be cured with
with with medication you're always going
to have it you will always be burned out
you're always going to be chronically
stressed that's your new identity it's
who you are you have anxiety right and
so we uh go to another doctor we open
another bottle of bourbon we start
working more and more hours and more and
more hours some of you weirdos just rub
essential oils all over your body
because whatever
because you guys believe in YouTube more
than right
lunatics so then
[Laughter]
you go see another counselor you talk to
a pastor you talk to a friend
and it's it's Madness
it's Madness
and you finally get the courage to say
hey I'm so anxious I can't breathe
I've got so much stress I'm on the edge
of burning out of everything
and I miss my husband
and I sit at my kitchen table once a
week when I've got all my family and I'm
surrounded by people I love and I am
deeply alone
we haven't slept together we haven't
been intimate in what feels like forever
and my marriage is crumbling and my kids
don't want to be in the same room with
me and I'm exhausted and I can't sleep
you look around and the world is
freaking falling apart
all right we're back listen is that you
are you sick and tired of being so
chronically stressed and anxious
everything's electric and listen you've
gone to all the experts you read all the
blogs
and though the way we're doing mental
health in this country is simply not
working it's not working
if this is you I got you if this is you
you're just like me
today is the first day you can pre-order
my brand new book building a non-anxious
life here it is I'm super excited about
it because
[Applause]
halfway through this book so I wrote
this book about anxiety and about
chronic stress all the stuff that we got
going on
and then halfway through
I stopped
and I went and checked myself into a
hotel I got away from my family for a
while
and I realized I'm not living this way
either
I'm not doing some of these things that
I was writing about and I had to control
all delete everything and so this book
is not me talking at you as so I'm like
I've got it all figured out this book is
me walking with you saying
we've created a world that our bodies
cannot exist in
and we've got to do something different
so look this book provides the six daily
choices that we all got to make to
overcome anxiety some of these are every
day some of these are every month some
of these are on an annual basis but
we've got choices to make about how we
live our lives they are practical
strategies I did not write a pop
psychology book and I also did not write
some super highly technical
jargon filled
um book for clinicians and researchers
how they talk to each other
this book is written for regular people
like you and me just trying to figure
out how to be a little bit better
parents how to stop the cycle of hurt
how to be less anxious how to come home
and create a home that is warm and full
of laughter and full of joy and this
crazy word that we don't even know what
it means anymore
peace
this is the um as they say highly
anticipated follow-up to my number one
bestseller own your past change your
future I don't know how many people are
highly anticipating this except for
maybe my mom listen no matter where you
start
you're going to gain a deep
understanding of what anxiety is what
it's not I did integrate some of the
stuff from redefining anxiety so if you
picked up that tiny quick read this is
going to be that book exploded and oh so
much more so much more listen anxiety
doesn't have to rule your life burn out
chronic stress all the things that we're
dealing with
there's an end point you can choose
something different all right the book
releases on October 3rd pre-stale starts
now so if you go pre-order the book
right now
20 bucks I'm gonna give you some of the
raddest bonus items so listen I want you
to get help today
so if you pre-order the book today that
talk that you just saw a piece of it I'm
gonna send you the whole talk right away
instantly you're gonna have access to
the whole thing
and so much more pre-order today at John
deloney.com go to John deloney.com
building a non-anxious life I'm super
excited I want to get this into the
hands of everybody
my neighbors my friends but honestly
myself
we gotta do something different and this
is the map
thank you so much for being in our gang
thanks so much for pre-ordering this
book hang on and we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hallow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hello.com deloney
all right we're back let's go out to
Reno Nevada and talk to the great
Valerie what's up Valerie
can you hear me okay oh my gosh that
sounds amazing how are you oh I'm good
thank you thank you for taking my call
of course of course so what in the
world's up
uh well I guess my question is
um How do I
forgive myself
for allowing someone to mistreat me how
do I move forward
wow that's heavy tell me more about it
um I was in um in a relationship with
this person for
almost two years
and um towards I guess the last uh maybe
eight months
um things got really bad he never
physically touched me but it was more of
like the verbal views and financially I
was dependent on him
for oh for the last six months and he
was always
like when we get into an argument and um
he would be like well I'm gonna take the
money out of the account and I would I
wouldn't have access to it
or he one time
got we got into an argument and my
family was in town and
he was drinking and he knew I was going
to need my car
and he ended up taking my car and
driving to a bar and I'm like trying to
reach him why did you take my car and
his answer was to make you feel
uncomfortable
hmm
do you all have kids do you all have
kids together
I we I got pregnant
to give a little bit more background I
cheated on him in the beginning of the
relationship and I got pregnant
and we both knew that we weren't sure
whether it was going to be his or not
and he decided that we were going to
continue and work on the relationship
but then when we took the test and it
was in his his reaction towards me and
the baby
completely changed sure
sure
all right um
foreign
directions a bit is that cool
that's fine
sometimes in a situation like the one
you're in
or a situation where we
fall in love with somebody we trust
somebody we take a job with somebody
and then they don't just not treat us
well but they hurt us
sometimes it's easier
to blame ourselves because we feel like
we could actually fix that
it's harder to live in a world
where somebody says I love you
and then strands you in the middle of
nowhere while you're pregnant
or somebody takes all the money out of
your account and says you have to go
through me
that world is terrifying because those
are supposed to be the the people that
ride or die with you right those are
supposed to be the people that love you
and so self-blame is often the easiest
place to go
foreign
but it's not right
and so what I would tell you is I don't
know that Valerie needs to beat up
Valerie Valerie doesn't need to forgive
Valerie because Valerie didn't do
anything wrong Valerie learned some new
information
some new lessons
right what Valerie has to do is learn to
live in a world where
you can be completely vulnerable in
somebody that you love is going to hurt
you
and then the question is who is going to
Valerie who who is Valerie going to be
on the back end of that
right that's a scary world right
it is
it's a scary world I'm sorry that he
treated you that way you didn't deserve
that
since I emailed you guys thanks
obviously changed and I've I moved out
and my family has my back and
it's just I feel
like I failed
yeah
what did what did you fail Valerie
foreign
I don't know I guess I wanted that
perfect family and yeah you what you
feel is grief
because you had a picture in your head
of how things were going to turn out and
then it didn't happen that way
and you have that that double-edged
sword right you would probably do
anything to take back cheating on this
guy
and getting pregnant and you get the
greatest gift in the whole world which
is a new baby right I I do and it's both
end
that's right it's both in and you
probably would
um look back and think well if I hadn't
done this and hadn't said this and
hadn't exploded on him in this one night
and I I I contributed to that's fine
but I want to tell you nobody
with an ounce
of
I'll just be very specific to men nobody
with an ounce of masculinity in their
body nobody with an ounce of dignity or
respect in their body
strands their girlfriend or their wife
ever
that's cowardly childish behavior
no man with any sort of masculinity any
sort of strength or dignity or
responsibility
takes all the money out of the account
and says you got to go through me as
though you're some kind of Overlord or
her dad
that's a cowardly childish behavior so
you are trying to look you're trying to
to
lean up against
a nine-year-old in an adult body and
wonder what you did wrong nothing
just a nine-year-old an adult body
his answer was always like well you did
this to me and it would always come
that's because he's a childish coward
he's a childish coward
my wife can't make me do anything
and I love her to the Moon and back
I choose my responses I choose my
actions I choose my thoughts I choose my
behaviors I choose I make choices
and she can frustrate me she can make me
sad she can break my heart she can make
me mad and then I choose what happens
next
and how dare any grown man
look at his friends his boss his wife
his kids and say you made me do bullcrap
he chose that
what you have to do is in a weird way
that's not even a weird way can I tell
you what I would recommend if you were
my sister or just a buddy of mine I
would recommend you hold some sort of
miniature vigil some sort of miniature
funeral for the picture you had in your
head of the perfect family
because you knew this baby was was not
his
and yet he said I'm in I'm in
he gave you an opportunity to Exhale and
to Dream a Little Bit
and if you're like most parents you
already have pictures of what your kid
coming home from college with some
knuckle-headed boy or some knuckleheaded
girl is going to look like and trying to
have Thanksgiving you already have those
pictures in your head and boom now
they're going to be different you have
to grieve that
I wanted this to happen and it's not
going to happen like this
it doesn't mean you're not going to have
joy doesn't mean you're not going to
have great relationships you're going to
fall in love again all those things are
still on the table and I would even go
as far as to say I think they're going
to happen
that you have to grieve I thought this
one was going to happen and it's not
all right
do you have lessons to learn from this
on how you responded to things
I
definitely right I mean for for once you
know
right cool
for that same reason I allowed myself
for him to do all those things you know
like I felt like I was looking for that
forgiveness
and he ran right over you
I knew I deserved better I just
stay there so so yeah but but again
I mean I I'm
I can read the data
and it's terrifying for a mom with a
young child to consider the possibility
that I'm going to be a single mom
unable to provide for us or it's going
to be a drastic shift in how me and my
baby live
and I can Shield my baby from the hell
that I live in in exchange for a roof
and that women have been making that
choice for centuries
you're not crazy and you're not broken
you're trying to stay safe and the
courage you showed leaving this madness
is incredible
and did you do dumb stuff yes
are we gonna do it again no because from
this point forward Valerie is a woman
who never ever cheats again Valerie's a
woman who never disrespects herself
somebody else's husband or her own
person that she's in a relationship with
that's it
period done
so let's set that brick down and quit
carrying it around everywhere
and by the way
this is for everybody listening and you
if
somebody cheats on you somebody hurts
you somebody breaks your heart
and you go through a period of being
upset and angry and grief all the normal
things
and then you have a moment where you sit
with them and you say hey I'm all in
we're gonna get through this we're gonna
work through this I'm all in
from that point forward you have to
um you can't hold this crap over each
other anymore you gotta move on
you can't grovel for the rest of your
life you'll have to regain rebuild
something new and then you have to
commit to being vulnerable again both of
you
and that didn't happen here
no
so let's do two things first thing is I
want you to
get a couple of your family members who
ride or die a couple of friends and I
want you all to hold a small little
ceremony for what was going to be it's
not
let's call it just a small little
funeral of the dream of the perfect
little family
I think you're gonna have a perfect
little family moving forward just gonna
look different than the one you had in
mind
let's have a small funeral for it and
then I want you to write Valerie a
letter
you
I want you to write what you learned in
this situation
the things that you wish you could do
over
I want you to to let Valerie know that
you love her
and here's who we're gonna be moving
forward
then the goal is going to be to create a
life where you can live into that
where you're going to exercise where
you're going to work who you're gonna
surround yourself with what you will and
will not tolerate in a romantic
relationship you get to pick all those
things
you get to choose that path forward
[Music]
I'm proud of you for for making the move
stay on the line I'm going to send you a
copy of on your past change your future
it's my last book and um
just gives you a path from
everything's in Ash and where I go from
here
thank you so much for the call Valerie
we'll be right back
all right we're back let's go out to
Caitlyn in Pittsburgh what's up Caitlyn
thank you hey what's up hey I pulled
into your show back in October yeah the
question then was along the lines of I
felt like I was placing trauma onto my
kids because of depression and
disassociation okay
my question today is I have lived all my
life numbing my emotions due to trauma I
don't know how to connect to myself or
emotions and emotions terrify me I also
feel paralyzed
paralyzed from Fear With Fear from
pretty much doing anything in life so
where do I start to connect to myself
animation without being paralyzed by
fear wow what happened
well as a child I was sexually abused by
my dad
how long did that go on Caitlyn
um quite a few years yeah
who ultimately took care of you
um my parents I I don't know
who came and rescued you Kayla
nobody
when did you finally Escape that Madness
so yeah it just all of a sudden stopped
did your mom know
uh no
does she know now yes
where's your dad now
um
go around
is he in jail um no I know apparently he
is currently in the process okay
oh man
I'm so sorry Caitlyn
um
I wish you'd had a better dad
little Caitlyn deserved that and teenage
Caitlyn deserved that and grown-up
Caitlyn deserved that
do you have kids of your own now
yes how old are your kids
um eight seven
or no nine eight six and two okay we may
have talked about this in the last
called it
have you found your own trauma responses
um escalating as you've added more kids
to the fold and they've gotten to
um the age you were when this madness
started
yes okay
are you going to talk to anybody
yes I'm I've been seeing a therapist
in the past
and it's not doing any good
um
she says she's say that I made a big
I've you know made a big change but some
a lot of the days I don't see it myself
okay
um I can tell you
from my personal experience and from
sitting with a bajillion people
the end of the day trauma disconnects
somebody from themself
well the way you described it that I
have trouble feeling I have trouble
connecting with my emotions is a perfect
way to to explain that
and if somebody hasn't been abused they
haven't experienced childhood trauma
they haven't experienced big trauma they
don't really understand what it feels
like to
literally be walking down the street and
feel disconnected from your own feet
or to feel like your body's on fire just
because you have a two-year-old crawling
all over you or
um you just want to scream and run out
of the house just because your kids are
laughing too loud
it's this disconnection from yourself so
the goal of any sort of
therapeutic intervention is
to reconnect with yourself
the hard part is
your body's put a pin in that as we
cannot do that again because the one
person who is supposed to keep us safe
our dad violated that
at its core
and so after a year and a half
um
if you haven't already you have to enter
into some sort of and this is from the
great Peter Levine's work you have to
enter into some sort of body work
that can look as simple as you having a
guided therapist that you trust who just
simply
puts their hands on you like on your
shoulders and on your head and on your
chest and on your arms as you go back
and re-experience some of these things
and teach your body what good touch and
Safe Touch feels like
or let me say it in another way you
can't talk and think your way through
healing on this
you might be a great candidate for some
of the newer procedures that are out
like the psychedelics and ketamine and
some of these other
therapies that are showing some great
clinical promise but you have to have
the right practitioner you can't just go
Crank that stuff out on your own it's
very very unsafe and unstable if you do
it by yourself
um but it may be that what happened to
you and for the duration of how it
happened to you was so profound
um and now you're surrounded by four
kids and so you're trying to change the
oil on this car while it's driving it
may be that you need to have some more
radical interventions with folks that
know what they're doing
some of my close close friends in the
military Community have just
just
told me wonderful incredible stories
extraordinary stuff
but you have to enter into a new phase
of okay I'm ready to reconnect
and just know that that's not fun and
it's scary
is that something you're interested in
Caitlyn
um yeah I mean it's definitely something
I want to do is to reconnect because I
don't want to continue living the way I
am right
so and the reason like the reason for
this call was my therapist is working on
emotions right now
and it seems like every single time I
try and do that
I go into this phase of suicidal
thoughts and everything yeah I I again I
your therapist has been working with you
for 18 months and so there's a lot more
than that your therapist can glean from
you than I can in a few minutes of a
phone call
um
I personally wouldn't be doing emotion
work right now
what you're describing is deeply seated
inside of you and your body
now if if he or she is trying to get you
to feel a certain thing in therapy where
it's safe in there to feel an emotion
and sit with it for a bit that might be
what's happening and you get flooded
with all kinds of wild thoughts
because your body's been working really
hard to not feel anything because last
time we feel something it was filled
with
um
pain and
innocence being stolen and all those
things
but at the end of the day I I think
having a direct conversation with your
therapist that I've been doing this for
18 months
and I'm ready ready to enter into a more
directive
focused healing
preferably around some sort of Bodywork
if we have to do emotion work great but
it's got to be done in a safe
therapeutic context which hopefully is
what your therapist is providing you
um
but it's at some point you can't keep
talking about the same stuff the healing
doesn't happen that way you have to
reconnect with your body that's the
disconnection that's the trauma
and your body's going to remain
overwhelmed by all these memories and
all these feelings and all these
emotions and all these Sensations
until your body learns hey we weren't
safe then and we are safe now and please
know everybody listening I know what I
am saying sounds like woo-woo I get it
I get it
but I can tell you personally I have
tracked my sleep score and my HRV as
I've entered through
um
this type of therapeutic intervention
and my whole life is changing
everything is changing
for the better as my nervous system
finally begins to slow down so all I
have to say is Caitlyn we're with you
we're with you
it's time to have a direct conversation
with your therapist about okay 18 months
in cool
it's time to make some changes we need
to do some body work we need to do some
more directive trauma work maybe some
EMDR and if not maybe it's time to get a
new trauma therapist or
it's time to look at some of these more
experimental
Solutions with guided practitioners and
researchers who know exactly what
they're doing
thank you
I'm grateful for you Caitlin I wish I
could provide you more instantaneous
like magic wand help here this is just
going to be a slog my promise is
there is healing on the other side if
you'll make the journey
please don't go alone we'll be right
back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life life so pre-order
building a non-interest life today for
just 20 bucks at John deloney.com
all right well that wraps it up for
today's show don't forget stop what
you're doing go pre-order my brand new
book building a non-anxious life go to
John deloney.com check it out it's going
to be everywhere and we'll give you all
sorts of cool bonus items John
deloney.com check it out and today's
song shout out to Valerie
shout out to Valerie from the great Amy
Winehouse
one of the most incredible voices of of
my entire life
um she left way too soon
song's called Valerie and it goes like
this well sometimes I go out by myself
and I look across the water and I think
of all the things what you're doing and
in my head I paint a picture because
since I've come home well my body's been
a mess and I've missed your Ginger hair
and the way you like to dress won't you
come on over stop making a fool out of
me
why don't you come on over Valerie
this song's kind of weird because that's
not my wife's name but it's cool
maybe it's about a puppy named Valerie
no
all right well I love you guys stay in
school don't do drugs go pre-order my
new book we'll see you soon
[Music]
foreign